supongamos que tenemos una función efe
que es continua continua en el intervalo
en a b déjame hacer un dibujo para que
podamos visualizarla por aquí vamos a
tener el eje de g
de este lado tenemos el eje t le voy a
poner t y no x porque la x la quiero
utilizar después y la función se ve es
más o menos aguas vale estar aquí es la
función esta es igual a efe dt ft
y como sabemos que es continua en la vez
y por acá ponemos a y por acá ponemos b
entonces la función es continua en este
intervalo sale es continua en esta parte
de acá ahora así nada más por pura
diversión vamos a definir otra función
que le vamos a poner f mayúscula de x y
la vamos a definir como la integral de
aa x de ft
dt y esta va a ser una función para las
equis que están en este mismo intervalo
entonces lo voy a poner para
x
ese mismo intervalo en el a como ve muy
bien entonces estoy acá para cada x nos
da un número y digo puedes decir mira
aquí tenemos una integral definida
entonces seguro tiene que ver con anti
derivar y con derivar pero espérate
tantito eso de ahí todavía no lo sabemos
lo hemos usado pero en realidad lo único
que sabemos de esta expresión es que es
un área esta es el área de a ax de x que
está por debajo de la función bueno de
la gráfica de la función de igual a etc
entonces marcando la en el dibujo sería
esta área de acá esta me la sale
muy bien lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es que realmente esto tiene que
ver con derivar o bueno con ser una
operación inversa a derivar vaya quiero
más o menos dar ideas para la
demostración del teorema fundamental del
cálculo y para esto vamos a derivar esta
función efe esta función efe pero lo
vamos a hacer con la definición entonces
qué vamos a hacer vamos a encontrar f
prima de x y por definición esto de acá
es igual al límite al límite de cuando
delta x tiende a cero de f de x más
delta x menos f de x y todo eso dividido
dividido entre delta x esto es la
definición de derivar muy bien ahora
vamos a sustituir estas ejes mayúsculas
por la expresión que les corresponde
entonces esto nos quedaría igual igual
al límite de cuando delta x tiende a
cero de aquí tenemos que poner x + delta
x osea la integral de a x + delta x
de ft dt y luego hay que restar fx o sea
esta expresión de acá la integral de x
de ft ft de super paseo que luego
tenemos que dividir entre belda x verdad
entonces ahora vamos a interpretar estos
estos términos pues acá en las áreas
para ver qué nos dicen back aquí tenemos
la integral de a x + delta x df de tdt
entonces aquí llegamos hasta x + delta x
así que déjame marcarlo por acá
aquí en algún lugar tenemos x + delta x
encima tantito la vez pero no las va
entonces el área que representa este
término de acá este término es el área
que ahorita voy a asombrar en color
verde en esta área
esta área hasta acá verdad desde a hasta
x 90 x muy bien entonces estoy acá es
esa integral y este sumando este otro
sumando el que va de x ya lo teníamos
marcado verdad es esta región entonces
al realizar la resta este es un área le
estamos quitando otra área y el área que
nos queda es esta área de aquí esta área
que voy a pintar en color morado para
indicar que viene de acá de la derivada
y esa área la podemos expresar como la
integral de x verdad ekis ekis ekis ekis
+ delta x de ft ft de este fantástico
muy bien entonces esta expresión la
podemos cambiar por esta de acá así que
vamos a reescribir f prima de x así la
vamos a reescribir como uno entre delta
x por el numerador que es éste acá
entonces nos quedaría por la integral de
x a x + delta x df de t de t
ok entonces mira ahora tenemos esta
expresión interesante pero esta
expresión suele aparecer cuando hacemos
cosas del estilo teorema de valor medio
para integrales definidas y para
acordarnos déjame escribirlo por acá
problema de valor medio para
integrales definidas definidas y dice lo
siguiente dice que si tenemos una cierta
integral en un intervalo entonces existe
un punto c en ese intervalo
entonces le voy a poner aquí existe ce
existe ce en el intervalo x coma x +
delta x
+ delta x tal que si tomamos ese s es
más déjame pintarlo voy a ponerlo por
acá queda entre los dos valores entonces
este de acá efe pero tal que si tomamos
este valor y nos fijamos cuánto vale la
función ahí aquí tiene cierta altura
fcc de verdad fcc y eso esa altura esta
altura de acá la multiplicamos por la
longitud del intervalo en el cual
estamos integrando aquí la longitud
sería delta x verdad porque es x + delta
x - x nos queda delta x entonces al
multiplicar frc por esa longitud del
intervalo obtenemos la integral déjame
escribirlo entonces
existe un ace en ese intervalo tal que
que delta x por fcc por frc es igual a
la integral de xx más delta x x más
delta x df de t
dt déjame bajar tantito o bien
dividiendo entre dividiendo entre delta
x obtenemos que fcc
es igual a 1 entre delta x por la
integral de x a x + delta delta x ft de
t ok esto está súper bueno básicamente
lo que nos dice es que este valor se es
como un valor medio verdad es un valor
promediado estamos sumando todos los
valores y dividimos entre la longitud
del del intervalo o bien otra forma de
pensar los en términos de áreas que si
esa altura promedio la multiplicamos por
la longitud del intervalo entonces vamos
a obtener exactamente el área que está
por debajo de la curva bueno entonces
vamos a utilizar esto para seguir con
nuestra derivada entonces déjame seguir
de este lado del lado izquierdo entonces
lo voy a poner así entonces
efe prima de x f prima de x es igual al
límite aquí me falta un límite verdad
este límite debía dejado poner aquí
igual al límite de cuando delta de x
tiende a cero límite límite límite f
prima de x es igual al límite de cuando
delta x tiende a cero
de acero de fcc porque mira es esta
expresión que aquí la tenemos pero eso
simplemente ofrece efe de c
entonces tenemos esta expresión de acá
como lo podemos hacer para pensarla ya
casi terminamos ya estamos nada más en
el último jalón mira pensemos lo tantito
intuitivamente que sucede con ce a pues
se queda encerrado entre equis y equis
más delta equis y aquí estamos tomando
el límite cuando delta x tiende a cero o
sea cuando estamos encerrando lo tanto
tanto que queda cerquita de equis
entonces pues más o menos acá
intuitivamente intuitivamente se tiende
a equis
no voy a poner así en color amarillo
entonces se tiende a x cuando cuando
delta x delta x tiende a 0 y como f es
una función continua si se se acerca x
entonces fcc se acerca a fx
la fx cuando
cuando delta de x delta de x tiende a
cero entonces pues a esta verdad porque
básicamente lo que estoy diciendo es que
si delta x tiende a cero
fcc fcc es igual cuando el límite de
cuando delta que tiende a cero de fcc es
igual a efe de x se se va x fcc se va a
fx entonces aquí nos queda fx2 pero
ahorita me has de estar diciendo oye no
opera este tantito este es el vídeo de
la prueba del teorema fundamental del
cálculo no estoy muy conforme con que
nada más me des la idea intuitiva y que
pues vayas al diagrama y me digas mira
se están acercando acá y se acercan acá
ya no mejor hay que dar algo un poco más
formal ok entonces vamos a probarlo un
poco más formalmente y para eso vamos a
utilizar el teorema del sándwich para el
teorema del sándwich es lo que nos dice
pues para acordarnos es lo siguiente
tenemos una cierta desigualdad en este
caso tendríamos tendríamos que lo va a
poner con color con color azul
tendríamos qué
x es menor o igual a c que es menor o
igual a x más delta x y entonces si este
lado se iba a un cierto límite y este
lado también lleva a otro límite
entonces lo de medio también pero para
esto necesitamos que lo del medio está
en función de una variable pero fíjate
esta c en realidad está en función de
delta x la podemos pensar como una
función de delta x porque si vamos
variando la delta x pues va cambiando el
punto c que es el valor medio entonces
vamos a pensarla como una función de
delta equis y aquí vamos a ver qué
sucede con el límite de las expresiones
de los extremos cuando delta x se va a
cero entonces qué pasa con el límite de
x cuando delta x delta x tiende a cero
xx no depende desde el está x verdad x
está aquí fijo entonces estoy acá
simplemente es x y de este lado que
sucede que pasa con con el límite con el
límite de cuando vuelta bueno el límite
de cuando vuelta x tiende a 0 de x más
resta x está pues desde aquí se va a 0
entonces simplemente nos quede igual a x
pues ahí está mira cuando delta x se va
a 0 esto se va x esto se va x y entonces
por el teorema del sándwich la expresión
de enmedio está de acá también se va a x
de esta forma el límite de cuando delta
x se va a hacer o de c de delta x es
igual a x entonces con esta obra sí ya
podemos terminar o sea esta expresión
esta c ahora sí ya tenemos un argumento
para decir que se va a x entonces se
tiende a x pero luego la función es
continua entonces fcc tiende a
fx esto nada más es una forma un poco
más formal pero un poco más rigurosa de
probar esto que ya habíamos dicho antes
básicamente que se se va xy que fcc se
va a fx muy bien hasta aquí tenemos
nuestra prueba tú estás súper padre
vamos a discutir un poquito qué nos dice
mira está muy bueno nos dice que si
tenemos una función continua la que
nosotros queramos en un intervalo coma b
y definimos esta f mayúscula de esta
forma como una integral entonces tenemos
lo voy a escribir por acá abajo por
reescribir básicamente tenemos que f
prima de x la derivada de esa función
que definimos es igual a efe de x es
este límite que encontramos con la
definición y pues porque para porque
esto está padrísimo o sea porque esto es
muy relevante pues está muy padre porque
eso de que a la fecha quita y le
asignamos la grandota se puede hacer
para cualquier función continua
y entonces para cualquier función
continua le asignamos una deja mayúscula
efe mayúscula que se puede derivar para
obtener la f original vaya está diciendo
que para cualquier función continua
siempre existe una anti derivada y eso
está bien padre por sí mismo pero lo que
está todavía más padre es que este
teorema fundamental del cálculo nos
ayuda a unir dos áreas super importantes
del cálculo derivar e integrar si nos
está diciendo que estas dos grandes
ramas del cálculo básicamente todo el
cálculo verdad están súper relacionadas
entonces qué pasa esta cosa que
inicialmente era un área la f mayúscula
la f mayúscula ahora sí la estamos
pensando pues como como una cosa que es
la operación inversa de derivar si
sacamos el área y luego derivamos
regresamos al original eso está muy
bueno entonces este teorema fundamental
nos da una relación derivar entre
derivar quiere sacar un área que perdón
que sacar una cierta pendiente e
integrar
e integrar
entonces por eso es el teorema
fundamental del cálculo y claro o sea o
sea lo hemos estado usando en más o
menos de manera intuitiva no lo habíamos
probado para nosotros pues la integral
hasta ahora nada más había sido un área
que habíamos definido como una área pero
gracias a esto que acabamos de demostrar
ahora sí estamos segurísimos de que
integrar y derivar están súper
conectados